hi I'm Kristen Goodwin on this episode
of the Fox News rundown President Trump
is shaking up his campaign leadership as
polls suggest he's trailing presumptive
Democratic nominee Joe Biden in the 2020
race are the polls accurate or is the
commander-in-chief when he says his
silent majority is bigger than ever
Georgia Republican Congressman Doug
Collins weighs in on the presidential
election his own Senate bid and the
Twitter Bitcoin hack and a number of
states are rolling back reopening
measures amid an uptick in Cova 19 cases
Charles Payne host of the Fox Business
network's making money with Charles
Payne discusses the state of the
nation's economic recovery and the
controversy over wearing face masks both
commentary by Pastor and Fox News
contributor Robert Jeffress the Fox News
rundown is a Daily News podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player by going to
FoxNews podcast.com Janis Dean I'm David
Asman I'm Dana Perino and this is the
Fox News rundown
[Music]
Friday July 17 2020 I'm Jessica
Rosenthal swings day pulling does not
look too good for President Trump but he
insisted this week the silent majority
is bigger than ever some of the leaders
in his base are feeling pretty confident
well we're gonna see I think from the
president going forward in August and
September and into November is you're
gonna see a focus president talk about
the accomplishment be that that no one
wants to get credit for I'm Chris Foster
checking in with how the economy is
doing during the corona virus outbreak
Fox Business Network strolls pain says
so far we've got a ways to go
but how far and how fast we've come here
in terms of the rebound is encouraging
it shows that a lot can be done
particularly everybody's sort of working
on the same page but it also underscores
I think just the fact that we've got an
amazing economic system and I'm Robert
Jeffress I've got the final word on the
Fox News rundown
so the summertime poling does not look
great for President Trump in national
polls former Vice President Joe Biden is
up as high as 15 percent swing state
polling though as we know it is where
it's at and those numbers indicate an
uphill battle for the commander-in-chief
as well the Real Clear Politics average
of polls in Michigan has Biden up about
seven points six points in Florida
nearly eight in Pennsylvania and six
points in Wisconsin the president was
asked this week during his Rose Garden
press conference if he's the underdog no
I don't I think we have really good poll
numbers they're not suppression Pauls
they're real calls he cited the lake
parties that have been happening in
certain areas with people plastering
their boats with Trump tent signs and I
think you have a silent majority the
likes of which this country has never
seen before
he says the enthusiasm is probably even
greater for his campaign than it was
four years ago
I think a lot of people don't want to
talk about it I think they're not gonna
say hey I'm for Trump on for Trump they
don't want to go through the process and
I fully understand that because the
process is not fair the media doesn't
treat us fairly
the Trump campaign has long argued that
polls are not to be believed questioning
the methodology of even the more
reputable ones something many of his
supporters agree with one of those
supporters has been in Congress in
Georgia for nearly eight years now and
he's battling for a Senate seat one the
governor appointed businesswoman Kelly
Leffler to when senator Johnny Isakson
retired early what we're finding in
Georgia's more and more of the folks are
coming and solidifying around us where
we're winning Republicans in the state
of Georgia with over 50% of the
Republicans right now Doug Collins is a
Republican congressman in Georgia and in
the jungle ballot which puts the
Democrats and everybody else on it as
well we're also winning in that people
in Georgia see who the you know the the
trusted trusted conservative is in this
race and that's us they know us they've
watched this over the last in a few
years in DC not only get things done
like the first step back in criminal
justice for him but they've also saw us
stand up to the liberal establishment of
flow Sein and Nadler and the rest and
chef and so they know who we are and so
that's what's making a difference with
voters because they know that I'm
fighting for them I was reading the
other day the president praised both you
and Miss Lafleur
and I thought that was curious are you
waiting or expecting an endorsement I
mean you you spent personal time with
the president would you expect an
endorsement at some point are you sort
of fine like riding this out on your own
terms the interesting thing here is
always the interesting question is you
know there's a sitting senator here and
he's not endorsed in this race instead
he was not and I think that says miles
because he understands what we've done
for him and he knew and he kept up with
my decision to run in this race so we're
look we're excited to be able to run
people know that he told the governor at
least three to four different occasions
he wanted me as this appointment and
people understand that and this
president is a very good politician
that's also the president a very good at
working and we're excited just to be
continued partners he said we're good
friends tell me are you surprised that
polling so far indicates such a tight
race between the president and mr. Biden
in your state and in Texas for that
matter well no to the Texas polls you
know and I've got friends in Texas the
Texas poll is the president will win
Texas that's just polling at this floor
out and you can do a lot with that in
Georgia the polling is tied at this
point but their president this time out
and 16 was tied in Georgia as well and
the in hero of inch the wanted Georgia
and this is something that sometimes the
national media doesn't focus on is less
I believe they should Georgia has never
been a Mississippi or an Oklahoma our
races statewide have not been 41
blowouts for Republicans we in fact the
largest was about 58% in 2006 and sonny
Perdue who was then governor was running
for a second term most of them have been
during the 52 53 51 range and so look
the president will do fine in Georgia I
mean I'm in it I'm in South Georgia and
here out in the middle of farm country
and on the side of the road you'll see a
hand-painted Trump sign best people who
are dedicated to to reelect in this
president he'll do fine in Georgia the
polling data for President Trump doesn't
look too good in the swing states we
know he just fired his campaign manager
what do you think you're arguably a
leader within his base what do you think
the president should be doing
differently if anything at this stage
what we're going to see I think from the
president going forward in August and
September and into November is you're
going to see a focused president talking
about the accomplishment these hats that
no one wants to give credit for it
just spent three and a half years trying
to tear him down waiting on this
November third election because they
didn't want him to win in 2016 they were
in here they were just beside themselves
when he won they didn't understand it
they thought doing that to keep him from
winning again and I fought against the
last 18 months a very direct attack
which has become almost obscene that
their acting is the political arm for
the Democratic Party to try and take him
down so he's gonna be focused he's gonna
focus on the economy kind of focus on
what's coming back from the pandemic
he's gonna focus on the trade agreements
that we've had he's gonna focus on
criminal justice reform which I was
proud to offer and sponsor with for him
and with him he's gonna fund and he's
going to talk about how we you know have
a stronger standing in many areas the
one on how we've helped our farmers in
our economy when he's focused on that
message he wins and when you contrast it
with Joe Biden and a different vision
for America people will respond to that
and I'm looking forward to seeing the
results on the river
I want to ask you about social media
because a lot of campaigning happens
there certainly on Twitter these days
and they just had a pretty significant
hack sounds like the the attackers got
ahold of internal Twitter controls in
order to carry this out
senator Holley is now calling they're
very security into question in just four
months before an election how worrying
is this we're always worried about
issues like that and I think first when
you when you can trace it back to where
it could possibly something from the
internal into a organization that does
carry such weight that's why you know
for many of us when you actually talk
about big tech and you talk about the
issues let's go into the heart of the
matter and that's the issues and not
only the security their data and the
security there's networks but also the
security of making sure that they are
not a Impa that they're not a partial
player and that's why section 230 which
is the safe harbor provision needs to be
modified or done away with because they
can no longer simply act as a bulletin
board they're actually an editing
publishing just like you and other media
outlets have to live under they should
have to live under the same standards
but when you're finding something it can
be internal that's an even bigger
problem
let's talk for briefly about the virus
this country has the most deaths of any
country and it is great that our
mortality rate isn't as bad as
had previously been but you know I'm in
California we're seeing people die
everyday and you look at a country like
you know some of the Asian countries
Japan South Korea I know we have
cultural differences there that are
stark but when you look at those when
you look at the differences it's so hard
to stomach you know where the United
States of America what happened
why are we so it's it I don't know I
don't know what to say when I death and
was just creeping up and these other
countries seem to be opening up and
doing fine and never really even did a
full shutdown like like we have in some
parts a lot of them having a also have a
cultural difference that accepts to shut
down a much more than then America and
we've always been very independent no
matter what party or what affiliation
we've been much more than independent in
body and a very much larger body in many
ways so we don't have the cultural and I
think you can't downplay that enough
there's not the cultural collectivism to
to do things like that but it but again
as you go through we're a much larger
sample we're looking through this but I
think we just have to continue to
maintain a proper perspective and
especially from an economic and a health
perspective there's a balance between
the two because there's a lot of you
know side effects and other things that
were happening as well does it concern
me yes there concerning any death
concerns me but we're really concerned
me early on especially in a large number
of our death
we're places like New York and other
places who were sending Kovac patients
back to nursing homes and in nursing
homes you were seeing the largest amount
of them rebuild Attica limited
environment closed environment in a
inside and that was just wrong so you
take away a lot of these deaths they
could have possibly been avoided and our
death numbers are high but they're not
on the levels of where they really work
so we just got to continue to balance it
both I share your concern but there's
also the concern of putting in
perspective of other issues that we're
dealing with they come across with
viruses and flus that we deal with on a
yearly basis here finally congressman I
want to ask you one of the police
shootings of a black man that caused a
lot of attention this year aside from of
course the death of George Floyd did
happen in your state in Atlanta Rashard
Brooks two officers have been charged
one with murder there have been reports
since of officers calling out sick
across the country you know it as the
blue clue on city officials talking of
you know
defunding police departments and have
even at this point voted you know to
move some funding around we know this
week and why p d--'s chief Monahan was
among those attacked by protesters it
looks like police reform though isn't
gonna happen in Congress anymore will it
this year I know because the Democrats
won't let it and and don't let secret
blows here anybody else told you the
House passed a Democrat plan I didn't
agree with that plan
but that's the way Congress works the
house will pass the Democrat plan
schools they're in the majority but the
Senate Democrats would not let Jim
Scott's bill be passed so that we could
go to conference and actually fix the
bill that's why actually you get things
done in Washington DC and then don't let
anybody fool you that the Democrats
humor and the rest of are the ones who
don't want police reform they want to
hold it for an election aspect now you
mentioned our short Brooks here in
Georgia we have a problem in Georgia in
Fulton County be a Paul Howard who
charged those officers without a grand
jury without the Georgia Bureau of
Investigation completing their process
of investigation now you just went ahead
and charged for political purposes he's
in a runoff down here and probably is
going to get beat and all he's trying to
do is pander for votes with the lives of
police officers when I see this moving a
defund police at the troopers kid my dad
was a trooper in Georgia for 31 years
I think this funding the police is
disrespecting the police and
disrespecting our civil society until
bill de blasio AOC the mayor Garcetti
and Los Angeles and others get there you
don't one do away with your own police
protection detail do away with them
tomorrow if you don't like blue the
number to get in a patrol car and
actually go through the job if you're
not willing to go get it into a car and
do the job and find out what's your
police officers are fighting just like
the officer who has choked the other
night in New York City and mayor de
Blasio had not the temerity to say
anything about that then getting the job
mayor de Blasio and go do the job or
otherwise shut on you know we we do here
though constantly and I hear it and I
see it on my social media feed this this
idea of systemic racism it's talked
about you non-stop these days do you
believe there is systemic racism
specifically within police departments I
think there's racism that we have to
face every day in our society that
certain individuals will a tribute and
to simply do what we're doing right now
to define the places how explain to me
even if you believe
that concept of systemic racism how is
that actually functioning to make this
better why don't you take what we did in
the in the house and what Jerry Nadler
chose not to free up when we went to
Houston in Detroit in Atlanta and
Washington we had we met with police
departments and communities with
different backgrounds different
political persuasions and found ways
that the police could work with their
communities and work in tandem with that
art Acevedo and and Houston and I know
we disagree on political issues but we
did we agree that the police and the
communities have to reflect each other
and have to be a part of the solution
together what we've got to realize is
there's bad actors just there's bad news
reporters just as there's bad ministers
there's bad people in the military
there's bad people that can be found in
police departments there's a very
minority of the the small percentage who
do it wrong we've got to find ways to
help the 99.9% of the police officers
get up every morning someone for very
little pay and very little benefit to go
out there and protect us every day and
we've got to focus on if they have a
racist police officers or racist people
they need to be removed from their job
racism has no place in our country
period in the statement and we've got to
make sure we're focusing on what is the
problem and not simply trying to make
blanket approaches to a sociological
issue of saying let's don't have a
police department let's give money to
organizations such as mental health and
drug addictions we need to do both
congressman Doug Collins thank you so
much for your time that's a great time
to be with you thank you
[Music]
this is Robert Jeffress with your
FoxNews commentary
coming up there was 18 weeks ago today
that President Trump declared a national
emergency over the corona virus outbreak
now in fits and starts in some places
seeing spikes and infections more
businesses have been reopening and the
president says the markets are very good
the country is doing well jobs are
growing fast Joe Biden says about the
recovery and what Congress has done with
taxpayer money to help stop taking care
of the Marla go crowd 40% of all the
money was supposed to go to small
businesses has gone to wealthy
corporations it hasn't gone to small
businesses and he's got his own economic
plans if elected as where we stand now I
would say ever had this coming up with
one word it would be remarkable
Charles Payne's the host of making money
with Charles Payne on the Fox Business
Network absolutely remarkable in the
backdrop of where we were
one two three four months ago and what
the experts said was not possible
obviously we've got a long way to go
there's no doubt about that but where we
are and what we were told we are we
would be at this point are night and day
and it's very encouraging everything
from retail sales to jobs numbers what
I'm seeing with manufacturing data
it's just absolutely remarkable it
speaks to an economy that it was
obviously very strong and had a lot of
momentum and maybe muscle memory as of
course it also speaks to trillions of
dollars an eighth that came very quickly
from both the Federal Reserve and a
federal government I think they've got
to kind of keep that happening because
they're still obviously gonna be a lot
of bumps ahead yeah I mean we're still
in this kind of stop and start mode in
some sectors in some parts of the
country be at another whatever 1.3
million layoffs and some of these people
are probably people that were laid off
and then came back and we're laid off
again a lot of people were claims you
got to be able to work a certain amount
of time to be considered there's also a
special program that doesn't get enough
publicity called the pandemic
unemployment assistance program because
of you're a sole proprietor
work for yourself there a whole lot of
job descriptions that don't even allow
you to get unemployment insurance
normally so they put this in place I'm
watching that very closely if that went
down a hundred and seventeen thousand
and then last week it's still around 14
million and so you know again this is
just an extra measure so but it does it
does go to your point and we've we've
got a ways to go but how far how fast
we've come here in terms of the rebound
is encouraging it shows that a lot can
be done particularly that everybody's
sort of working on the same page but it
also on the scores I think just the fact
that we've got an amazing economic
system in place and when it's allowed to
operate it does very well the reopening
the shutting down the stalls that's
gonna probably see you'll see more of
that reflecting and data over the
incoming weeks but I think overall the
momentum can be sustained but I think
the key is going to be with Congress
coming back and doing another round of
stimulus and I think the numbers got to
be 1.5 trillion or better yeah I was
gonna ask you do think that Congress
should and will throw a lot more money
at this state and local governments are
gonna get killed in tax revenue and even
for people who say they want small
government those are still jobs and
there are cops and their teachers and
their firefighters and garbage
collectors and and those people need to
be paid for so it and also just
politically don't you think the
president needs to push first the
throwing some more money at this the
president's talked about actually larger
checks it's some of the more fiscally
conservative folks in the cabinet and
some of the opinion makers to shape the
old conservative orthodoxy you know I
think even with what we've seen so far
there have been special carve outs for
essential workers front line workers
yeah I mean there are legitimate
concerns about paying off the pension
funds of Illinois right in of Illinois
or paying off with special programs in
New York City that that have nothing to
do with koban 19 and we know money is
fungible so once you throw it in a pot
there's no telling where it came from
but I think the administration's going
to definitely make sure they take care
of those essential workers
those frontline workers but by the same
token it there's gonna be a fight over
the additional $600 because about 60
some-odd percent of Americans are making
more money being unemployed than a dent
being employee and and you can't get a
recovery if we can't get small business
businesses up and running and - and by
now - many small business owners have
said listen I can't I told people were
open and they don't want to come back to
work
and you know so the flip side of that
yesterday Chipotle announced 10,000 new
jobs because of the way people are
ordering you know and you know the
curbside pickup the drive-in windows
Pizza Hut got 10,000 dominoes pizzas got
10,000 Dunkin Donuts 25,000 McDonald's
is hiring 260,000 more subway so you
know there are certain things that are
happening in this economy that that are
positive ironically from the COBIT 19
yeah and there are certain things that
we just we're gonna need help to get
through we're gonna definitely have more
speed bumps out there so it would be
political suicide not to do it and I
think it would be dumb economic policy
not to do it who's doing what you
mentioned who's doing well who has been
thriving in spite of the pandemic or
even because of the pandemic you know
people who have the privilege of working
from home you know people who have been
able to do their work on laptops and
computers and you know their their their
their incomes haven't been hit at all
and then of course you know the adoption
of some of these things you know last
quarter PC sales were up oh man I think
the number I want to say 73 million
units this is around the world but
mostly driven in America the quarter
before that it was 50 million and and we
were getting articles that were
declaring the death of PCs and laptops
so you know these are the kind of things
that are being carved out that are
really doing very very well and and it's
a privilege to be to work from home your
paycheck probably hasn't been disrupted
and these companies that can do business
online are taking more market share
these the larger companies obviously are
doing the best and because they're
smaller
going on a business it's kind of a
bigger picture longer-term thing how
would you feel about being in commercial
real estate in the big city right now do
you think a lot of you think companies
are gonna be like oh my god we don't
need this footprint everybody can stay
home well just anecdotally my I have my
own research firm and we'd already moved
out of Wall Street to Jersey a year and
a half ago now two years ago and and the
reason I did that is because when I
first started the business you had to be
in Wall Street you know my firm Wall
Street strategies I was on Wall Street
and back then it gave you a certain
amount of cachet you know you call
someone up from from Kansas City and
they want to do business with someone on
Wall Street now that's not the point
so my lease was up and I decided not to
renew it and maybe I'll do it again
I do love an office atmosphere I think
it does help with productivity but right
now you know I decided not to do it so
commercial real estate I think was
already starting to get hit a little bit
in New York City in part to over
building but now commercial real estate
is gonna be a huge huge challenge really
huge challenge not getting back to
politics but the president's big
advantage has always been seen as the
economy and now his polls are slipping
there one of them
Quinnipiac I think it was has him
head-to-head with Biden as is who was
gonna be better to get us out of this
economically and now Biden's economic
plans are out what do you think voters
are gonna think about that look at their
own personal situation the community
situation and momentum momentum is
always important so for me for President
Trump to be reelected he needs to
October surprises and the good news from
him for him is that all of this third
quarter stuff will be announced the days
before the election so what happens in a
third quarter GDP is up 25% retail sales
came in significantly better than
anticipated if those keep going up it
wages begin to rebound and then the
second part of that again would be I
think vaccine is the administration put
another 1.4 billion into a company
called Nova backs so they're putting
billions of dollars into operation
warp-speed and so far it's paying off
the news that we're getting from the
modernity of the world the AstraZeneca
of the world the sizes of the world the
nova batches of the world are giving us
a lot of hope so yeah i think i think
people will they really think about it
and say where was the economy in
February and and and and they base their
economic assumptions on February I think
the president would have a clear
advantage because we were juggernaut in
February before this disease came out of
left him a food fight between some
liberals and President Trump and his
supporters last week the CEO of Goya
foods was at the White House saying that
we're blessed to have a leader like the
president McCoy has a Latin American and
Spanish food company based in New Jersey
that prays for the president has some
Democrats and opponents of the president
calling for a boycott that led to
President Trump and his daughter Ivanka
posing for pictures with Goya products
and calls to buy more of the brand it's
heartbreaking that someone can't say hey
Thank You mr. president Trump and then
Irene is that of course Agassi went to
the White House he was presented with an
award from President Obama and then he
followed that up with a joint venture to
help feed people with Michelle Obama so
it should never become a political niche
in the first place
Charles Payne Fox Business Network
Saverio and thanks for coming out today
Charles talk to you later
you got it
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from Fox News for Amazon
Alexa Jessie Alexa plain news from Fox
in Fox News it's the latest when you
need it on demand from Fox News and
Amazon Alexa subscribe to this podcast
at Fox News podcasts calm now some good
news with Tanya J powers one of the
original Rosie the riveters is doing her
part once again to help her country as
the u.s. battles kovat 19 May Cryer is
94 and she went to work in may of 1943
building b-17 and b25 a smash to prevent
the spread of the corona virus she told
the Bucks County Pennsylvania courier
times that she makes the mask collector
red polka dot bandanas made popular by
the Rosie's they were the women who went
to work in manufacturing plants to make
supplies for the military members
serving overseas they tied their hair
back in bandanas so it wouldn't get
tangled in the machinery May has been on
a crusade to have the Rosie's honored
with the Congressional Gold Medal
shortly after the 75th anniversary of
d-day last year the US House of
Representatives passed a bill to make
the medal happen then sent it to the
Senate which so far has not followed
suit crier had been going around the
country to try and convince the Senators
to sign on but she had to stop in March
due to Kovan 19 she says she started
making the rosie masks to keep from
getting bored and says requests have
skyrocketed crier says if the mask can
help raise awareness to get the senate
to okay the gold medal for the Rosie's
she's fine with making more of them
saying quote it keeps our legacy alive
Thank You Mae and all the Rosie's Tonya
J powers Fox News
[Music]
it's time for your Fox News commentary
Robert Jeffress what's on your mind
Daniel Lewis Lee is dead after a flurry
of court challenges and last-minute
delays an early morning 5-4 ruling by
the Supreme Court allowed the execution
to proceed on Tuesday it had been 17
years since the federal government
executed a death row prisoner the
reinstitution of the death penalty shows
a commitment by the Justice Department
to uphold the rule of law carrying out
the sentences given by our nation's
judicial system capital punishment has
been a contentious issue in our country
for the last half-century many states
have curtailed their use of the death
penalty or outlawed the practice
entirely opponents to the death penalty
often claim that it is a cruel and
unusual punishment outlawed by the
Eighth Amendment of the Bill of Rights
however this is a modern fiction it has
been the clear and consistent practice
of our country from the days of our
founding to uphold the integrity of the
law by allowing the ultimate sentence to
fall on those who commit the ultimate
crimes Christians are often accused of
inconsistency here how can you be
pro-life and still be for the death
penalty which extinguishes alive the
Bible's teaching is clear the death
penalty is a testimony to the sanctity
of human life God told Noah whoever
sheds the blood of man by man shall his
blood be shed for God made man in his
own image Genesis 9 verse 6 the death
penalty is a just and proportional
response by society to the intentional
destruction of human life it upholds the
dignity of the innocent person made in
God's own image individual Christians
have been called by Jesus Christ to show
love and forgiveness to their enemies
refusing to take vengeance into their
own hands but the government itself does
not bear the sword in vain and carries
out God's wrath on the
wrong-doer through its justice system as
Paul wrote in Romans 13 verse 4 we live
in an age of squeamishness and
relativism when many governments are
advocating their god-given
responsibility capital punishment should
be the way our society pronounces its
righteous judgment on the most heinous
crimes committed by the most evil people
don't forget what we're talking about
here these Federal convicts put
themselves on death row by brutally
murdering innocent people by resolutely
saying no to their evil we are saying
yes to life this is Robert Jeffers
pastor of the First Baptist Church in
Dallas Fox News contributor and author
of the new book courageous
you've been listening to the FoxNews
rundown and stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at FoxNews
podcasts calm and for up-to-the-minute
news go to Fox news.com
love FoxNews click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the FoxNews rundown
playlist for the latest episodes